coming to the bargaining table about
reopening schools
we've been in discussions negotiations
with the district around what those
conditions of return would be
the clark county education association
and the clark county school district
talk safety safety is one of the first
and foremost critical pieces
ccea executive director john valardida
says it remains a top priority
this follows the board of trustees not
voting on the proposed transition plan
last week
with details about certain precautions
did you not think the reopening plan
was robust enough no it did not have
well up to thursday it did not have
the type of safety program that that's
one piece of what we were advocating for
did not have it in place the teachers
union lists certain needs including a
cova testing
screening and contact tracing program
the people test positive
and then all the other bells and
whistles protected produce
personal equipment social distancing
measures enforced
sanitation measures ventilation not just
in the buildings but on buses
talks also incorporate the hybrid model
that's when students attend school
two days in person and continue distance
education
the other part of the week how does that
work i mean
what kind of workload does that present
to an educator
is it effective in terms of instruction
ccsd will present the transition plan
again to the board of trustees in
january 2021
kristin drummond 8 news now